die weltverbesserer mit globetrotter im
spezialist für maßgeschneiderte reise
wartet seit über 40 jahren
globetrotter punkte sind für menschen
dar denen es weniger gut geht
sie handeln wenn andere noch regen
sie machen die welt zu einem besseren
ort
sie sind
die weltverbesserer war neubauer ist
hoffotograf des dalai lama in nepal will
er das dorf samt das vom klimawandel
bedroht ist an einem besseren ort neu
aufbauen
jetzt sieht er zum ersten mal die neuen
häuser die junge ärztin melanie holz
gang leitet die unfallchirurgie in einem
äthiopischen spital
ihr ehemaliger chef jörg pelzer
unterstützt sie für eine woche gemeinsam
versuchen sie das leben der kleinen
regina zu retten was besagt familie
wann er zum norwich setzt sich für
flüchtlinge auf der balkanroute 1
in der schweiz stand sie zusammen mit
ihrem sohn kraft für ihren neuen einsatz
im norden griechenlands
wir sind die mühle im kanton aargau man
ja zur neuen beach besucht mit ihrem
sohn noel anna maria scherer
sie ist volontärin bei warners verein
wurde anna marias mann rolf ist
ebenfalls dabei anna maria war auch im
serbische presse wo im einsatz
das hat sie tief beeindruckt nun will
sie jeden tag an diese zeit erinnert
werden
[Musik]
alle maria hat ein käppchen presse wo
ein anderes motto free getauft
[Musik]
dann überrascht anna maria mit ihrer
ankündigung dass sie bald einen weiteren
freiwilligen einsatz machen wolle
[Musik]
in der äthiopischen stadt im leben um
die 200.000 einwohner die meisten
menschen haben nicht mehr als zwei
stunden am tag zur verfügung
die hauptstadt addis abeba ist knapp 350
kilometer entfernt mit dem auto dauert
das sechs bis zehn stunden
melanie holz gangs ehemaliger chef jörg
pelzer unterstützt sie für eine woche in
der klinik pelzer reist seit vielen
jahren nach äthiopien vor 13 jahren
baute er diese unfallchirurgie auf und
er hatte die idee mit einsätzen für
schweizer chirurgen
obwohl er jedes jahr einige wochen hier
verbringt ist er noch immer von der
vielfalt der fälle überrascht ein
flusspferd hat diesen jungen beim baden
gebissen
[Musik]
es ist nicht so groß es war ein kleines
flusspferd war es wirklich ein
flusspferd
da hatte es getötet
da hatte aber glück gehabt
nun steht ein schwieriger eingriff bevor
ein mädchen mit einer schweren
blutvergiftung muss notoperiert werden
sie ist neunjährige und ihre eltern
holten nach einer armverletzung dem dorf
schamanen erst tage später wurde sie ins
spital gebracht
die eltern hoffen dass der arm doch noch
gerettet werden kann
foto wirklich sich leicht vom netzwerk
name wird sich da aber es gibt auch
andere fall wohnen dienen ist vor der
patienten damit würde ich sterbe und den
was weniger wichtig dass man amputiert
oder zumindest not vermessen aber dass
notfalls innerhalb der ganzen emotionen
mit familie dass ich habe speziell nach
45 minuten ist der eingriff vorbei führe
hemer ist es ein eingriff in ihr ganzes
weiteres leben
[Musik]
menschen mit einem handicap haben in
äthiopien kaum eine chance auf ein
normales leben
sie finden keine arbeit und ihre
familien müssen sich um sie kümmern
sonst bleibt ihnen nur das battle
[Musik]
das atelier des fotografen manuel bauer
in winterthur er bereitet sich auf seine
nächste reise nach samsung dem dorf das
umsiedeln muss vor
vor drei monaten ist er aus nepal in die
schweiz zurückgekehrt hin und her dass
meine tochter an das land touren kann
sie entschieden vom land von könig 2 mit
sorge ob sie einen kunden kunden kaufen
vortag
leider zählen jetzt nach niger sind dann
doch finanziell steht das projekt gut
das ganze bau holz hängen können
finanzieren und das noch übrig blieb im
moment hat manuel bauer 160 tausend
franken zur verfügung
dank ihm und spendern entsteht in nepal
ein neues dorf
dorthin sollen die bewohner von samsung
das von wasserknappheit bedroht ist
umziehen
der fotograf ist gespannt die baustelle
in mustang wieder zu sehen
denn es geht um die existenz von 85
menschen
auf dem nachhauseweg telefoniert waren
ja zur neue witsch wie so oft mit ihrem
verein bode free association neue lebt
bei den großeltern auch wanja wurde von
ihren großeltern in bosnien aufgezogen
ihre eltern arbeiteten in der schweiz
und holten sie beim ausbruch des
bosnienkrieges nach flüchtlingen helfen
und etwas zurückgeben
das ist die eine welt von wanja ihr sohn
die andere
[Musik]
wieso spielt weil sie einweisen
jetzt im moment ist die flüchtlingskrise
ich muss es einfach mein herzenswunsch
wenn sie sich einfach priorität und ich
finde er liebt und dass ich darin nicht
vernachlässigen dem ziel aber ich muss
mich jetzt langsam immer recht weit
überlegen
vom kinder sind immer die mit facebook
die wirkliche bildeten buchstabe kinder
im kinderkino schlüsse also ich mit
meinem sohn und er muss es auch versteht
zusammen mit neuen versucht sich wanja
von ihrer aufreibenden arbeit mit
menschen auf der flucht zu erholen
das gelingt nicht immer
es ist ablenkung von abschalten
[Musik]
im gym der stadt in äthiopien sind die
60 betten der unfallchirurgie voll
belegt wie immer ihr pelzer und melanie
holz gang sind auf dem weg zur ehinger
dem neunjährigen mädchen das am vortag
beinahe gestorben ist
viele patienten finden nur in einem bett
auf dem korridor platz ihre angehörigen
betreuen sie um das leben zu retten
musste ihr linker arm amputiert werden
jetzt müssen wir erklären wieso wir es
tun mussten und dass wir die wunde
operativ verschließen müssen in der
lokalen sprache amharisch klärte arzt
den vater auf er ist klein bauer und
vater von zehn kindern
er ahnt dass regina ein schwieriges
leben erwartet
[Musik]
havanna
sie sucht ihren unterarm ja ja ich weiß
[Musik]
der vater befürchtet das regime mit
ihrer behinderung im dorf zur
außenseiterin wird er hat angst dass sie
keine zukunft hat erkläre ihm dass wir
versuchen später eine prothese zu
organisieren
der arm tut es gab kein weiches
lebendiges gewebe mehr
die operation war lebensrettend
schließlich will ich der vater einer
weiteren operation zur verschließung 1
er ist einverstanden mit dem verschluss
aber er will die wunde sehen
ok amputieren wege schlimm psychosoziale
dort das niveau der anfall sich zum
glück nicht rechtens und unser linke
will mir ist mit rechter hand
aber die prothetische versorgung von
armen so viel komplexer als das
alltägliche bison an funktionalität
[Musik]
in diesem haus in winterthur lebt der
fotograf manuel bauer mit zwei anderen
familie
es gehört einer stiftung und er bezahlt
einen teil der miete mit seinen bildern
so kann er mehr zeit für sein
unbezahltes projekt in nepal und für
seine familie aufwenden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die betreuung seines sohnes jahre teilt
er sich zur hälfte mit seiner ex-frau
sofern er nicht im ausland ist york ist
14 jährig und schwerbehindert fast
täglich hat er epileptische anfälle
im frühling wurde er zudem am rücken
operiert nur so konnte eine
fortschreitende krümmung der wirbelsäule
verhindert werden
manuel begleitet ihn in einem büchlein
protokollieren die betreuer yorks
aktuellen gesundheitszustand zweifelten
aber das ist jetzt quasi nimmt dem bund
fast alle aufgesetzt dass ein frieden
ist
wir haben und muss sagen das ist schon
das heads up also viel sehr viel braucht
oder also sieht mir fremd sind und die
dann so genannte nach prinzip bleiben
was ich sehr empfehlen
es ist super dass ein kind in dem ort
liebe das sind und andrea und ich mache
sagt als mir darum heißt nach stall
flüge wie für vilimsky beton energien
und herzlicher und den jungen auch
marika manuel 16 jährige tochter und
joris schwester lebt im haus marica
besucht das gymnasium und hat früh
gelernt verantwortung zu übernehmen und
sich um ihren bruder zu kümmern dass ihr
vater oft im ausland ist daran hat sich
marica gewöhnt einmal durfte sie ihn
nach indien begleiten
[Musik]
die waren ja zu neuem schlägt auch
manuel bauer in zwei welten
das gehöre für ihn zum leben sagt er
sein engagement hier sei für ihn
gleichwertig wie das engagement
operation
und dass die solidarität
aber die muss ein großer platz
kein problem
[Musik]
die domain im norden griechenlands ist
ein wildes camp entstanden
seit der grenzschließung von mazedonien
anfang jahr sind jetzt 10.000
flüchtlinge blockiert und leben unter
desolaten bedingungen weil im serbischen
presse wohl nur noch wenige hundert
flüchtlinge sind hilft man ja zur neue
wird jetzt hier von der schweiz aus flog
waren ja alleine nach griechenland um im
grenzort die domain flüchtlinge zu
helfen
also situation hart langsam muss stimmen
mehr
[Musik]
vieles erinnert an die adresse wo dort
war sie zu beginn auch alleine unterwegs
auch dort gab es zu viele flüchtlinge
und zu wenig helfer man ja ruft ihrer
followers auf geld zu spenden
daher trifft auf ahmed und seine familie
das ist unser baby eine kleine kleine
süße dem sie ist krank seit drei tagen
wir können keine medikamente verteilen
das ist verboten aber ich bring euch zu
einem arzt viele kinder hier sind
erkältet und leiden an fieber und
durchfall
wie heißt sie und sie schöner name
alle sind krank immer mehr mütter
schließen sich ihnen an
ein junge wie heißt er
arbeitest du hier ja ich brauche einen
arzt
nein fünf babys brauchen einen doktor
außerhalb des camps kommt rooney
preschen fand man ja bei der
organisation mit softwareunterstützung
[Musik]
im universitätsspital von china
existiert eine einzige unfallchirurgie
für zehn millionen menschen wie das
ganze spital ist sie völlig veraltet
chinesische investoren finanzieren nun
ein neues universitätsspital york
peltzers vision ist es hier mit seinem
großprojekt seine unfallchirurgie neu
aufzubauen
hier wird der eingang der
unfallchirurgie sein
die notfall abteilung kommt hier hin
hier kommt die patienten station hin mit
120 betten und dort kommt der operation
zu nehmen peltzers traumazentrum soll
mehr patienten versorgen können
aber auch die ausbildung für ärzte
verbessern von den veranschlagten 20
millionen franken fehlen aber noch 15
millionen pelzer hofft dass in der neuen
unfallchirurgie der einst spezialisten
für ganz afrika ausgebildet werden wenn
2017 das neue uni spital eröffnet wird
will pelzer mit dem bau beginnen
das ist jetzt doch eckpunkt der warmen
schein und ruf und eine gold- oder ich
hatte über zum biocenter und da ich habe
das problem noch zum regler mit mitte 70
selbst geklagt habe das muss ich offen
ob er seinen traum einer modernen
unfallchirurgie in china verwirklichen
kann ist unklar
viele fragen sind noch offen
in der zwischenzeit unterzeichnet
melanie holz gang die präsenz
bestätigungen der assistenzärzte es
kommen noch mehr egal ich unterzeichne
wohl testate für das ganze jahr
unglaublich noch eine unglaublich ich
fühle mich wie ein popstar wie die
anderen weltverbesserer lebt auch jörg
pelzer in zwei welten
er ist chefarzt in delsberg und
engagiert sich seit 13 jahren für das
großprojekt und die stiftung schweizer
chirurgen in äthiopien nächste peter
weiß dass bürokratie und korruption sein
vorhaben behindert werden
[Musik]
links
in nepal macht sich der fotograf manuel
bauer mit la manawan seinen freund und
engsten mitarbeiter auf dem weg zum
neuendorf
von der schweiz aus flog er in die
hauptstadt nepals kathmandu von dort
reiste er über chanson ins ehemalige
königreich muster nach lohmann kann und
weiter ins neue dorf name schon
[Musik]
wer im ehemaligen königreich muss dann
unterwegs ist braucht bis heute eine
sondergenehmigung und viel geduld
manuel bauer wird bald zum ersten mal
sein neues dorf sehen
seit dem letzten besuch vor drei monaten
wird auf dem land das der ehemalige
könig von muss dann den bewohnern von
samson geschenkt hat gebaut
hierher sollen sie später umziehen
aber sie haben sie sowohl super meint
das ist ja wahnsinn
juli august die 2
ich hoffe sie sind
das sieht sehr viereckig und hat dabei
alle gleich aber nach flüchtlingslagers
von aber es kann ja wie qsc warum der
übersetzer der die bauleitung übernommen
hat heißt ihn als erster mit der
traditionellen katar willkommen sie
warnt geht's gut alles gut
schön dich zu sehen
alle dorf vertreter sind versammelt wie
geht's gut
du siehst gut aus endlich wird manuel
das neue dorf in das er acht jahre
seines lebens investierte betreten die
domäne sind die menschen blockiert weil
mazedonien die grenze geschlossen hat
wanja will drei syrischen familien
helfen
es ist besser wenn ihr mit uns kommt und
das kauft was ihr wirklich braucht ich
muss mich umziehen
warum ihr seid so gut angezogen egal und
er kann selber kaufen was ihr braucht
das ist besser du schwanger darunter und
mehr schaffen ist froh da somit finden
schluss sa und dann wird mir langsam und
suchen immer wieder neue familie
die lebensmittel bezahlt waren jetzt
neue beach mit dem spendengeld dass der
verein wurde früher association
gesammelt hat und fleisch in das taxi
wird war ja mit den lebensmitteln zurück
zur zeltstadt fahren kaffee für dich und
das andere bringe ich später wir müssen
ab machen wo wir uns treffen nicht im
camp sonst kommen alle
wir treffen uns beim sträßchen
lebensmittel sind knapp
wanja befürchtet probleme mit anderen
flüchtlingen
linde
in der äthiopischen stadt wimmer ist
melanie holz gang wieder auf sich
gestellt jörg pelzer ist in die schweiz
zurückgekehrt melanie ist auf visite bei
riemer deren arm amputiert werden musste
es ist trocken um eine zweitmeinung
einholen zu können
fotografiert melanie die wunde
abgeklärt
prima drohen weitere operationen
wir müssen sie täglich kontrollieren
wenn er schlechter wird müssen wir sie
wieder behandeln
riemer hat neun geschwister für die
operation muss ihr vater ein kleinbauer
umgerechnet 30 franken bezahlen
für ihn ein vermögen auch melanie ist
kümmert
ihre 83 jährige großmutter bei der sie
nach dem tod der mutter gelebt hatte hat
eine schwere erkältung melanie will
wissen wie es ihr geht und telefoniert
in die schweiz
beide lieben fremdsprachen
[Musik]
ok also machen wir machen einfach sogar
das 7
das passiert aber das weiß man hat mir
und das rolltor umziehen
von daher bliebe auch das haben die
weltverbesserer gemeinsam die sorge um
ihre lieben in der heimat
[Musik]
mama schon so heißt das neue dorf dass
manuel bauer ermöglicht hat es liegt auf
3700 metern höhe im gegensatz zu samsung
gibt es hier genügend wasser um später
die felder zu bewirtschaften
11 von insgesamt 18 häusern sind gebaut
manuel der fotograf dokumentiert die
fortschritte für sich und für die
spender
sehr schön sieht wie ein gefängnis aus
für die menschen aus samsungs sind diese
häuser moderne es hat fünf fenster
einige von ihnen wollen keine fenster
hier drin haben weil ja es ist ja ein
leider raum
ich habe ihnen gesagt jetzt seid ihr
hinter neuzeit angekommen
da braucht ihr fenster ihr braucht mehr
licht
es ist wichtig dass jeder raum einen
ausgang hat auch für den notfall
wir haben einen hof einen
gemeinschaftsraum einen andachtsraum ein
wohnzimmer und einen lagerraum das
wohnzimmer wird auch für die gäste
benutzt als schlafzimmer in einem haus
gibt es also vier räumen
willst du dieses haus anschauen wie du
willst lasst das im sommer offen
dann ist es wie ein hof genau sehr schön
young und im sommer ist die küche hier
draußen
für wie viele menschen ist das haus
gedacht für zehn personen
das geht gut manuell hofft dass sobald
die felder ernte abwerfen alle einwohner
von samsung nach mama schon umziehen und
so auch die abwanderung in die stadt
verhindert werden kann
ein derartiger weise
die sind dann erscheint liegt auch
glücklich sind und liefert oder mirka
zentrum war hannes hofbauer zum mir
geht's um das delikt später zufrieden
sind
das werden wird die nutzers und liefert
und singend auf den fall der früheren
und dem hsv
das war glück 18 häuser an erstellen das
ist eine lösung
[Musik]
im griechischen idomeneo hilft wenn er
zur neuer patch außerhalb der zeltstadt
drei familien bei der aufteilung der
gekauften lebensmittel
andere flüchtlinge kommen hinzu und
möchten auch etwas haben geld ich will
geld das hier ist für drei familien
du musst mir eine liste machen mit allem
was du brauchst und ich gehe einkaufen
er soll seine frau fragen
sie weiß besser was das benötigt
zurückstehen bitte zurück alle g zu
euren familien und nach die listen ich
warte fertig nein sie sind wütend warum
sie glauben uns nicht
dann sollen sie sieben sein lassen ich
arbeite freiwillig und gratis hier
wenn ihr uns nicht glaubt ist das euer
problem
er sagt einige verkaufen die waren auf
dem markt
wir müssen den menschen vertrauen sagt
ihm wir helfen ihm wenn er will
aber er muss ruhig bleiben dann bringen
wir ihn heute die nahrungsmittel vorbei
okay das war eine person pro familie
schreibt eine liste der nahrungsmittel
die er braucht nicht auf die
reisedokumente schreiben und den kunden
langsam täter suchen sich sehen dass das
mehr menschen finden das mir wirklich
helfen
hier lagert ihr alles ein riskantes
versteck das ist für fünf familien
das reicht nicht aus er teilt das ja
miteinander machen
wenn jetzt neue mit hat ihre lektion
gelernt
[Musik]
in der unfallchirurgie im gym wird die
neunjährige china schon fast zwei wochen
behandelt
ihr vater pflegt sie und weicht nicht
von ihrer seite
noch immer ist die entzündung nach der
amputation nicht ganz abgeklungen
aber ihren schalk hat die neunjährige
wiedergefunden
in der nächsten folge geht es rechner
besser die ärztin melanie holz kann
freut sich über das wiedersehen aber
bald muss sie von äthiopien abschied
nehmen
wann er neue witsch sucht in
griechenland nach immer neuen
möglichkeiten nahrhafte und günstige
mahlzeiten für die flüchtlinge zu
beschaffen will
manuel bauer kann zusehen wie das neue
dorf mama schon immer mehr gestalt
annimmt
bald können die häuser bezogen werden
[Musik]
die welt verbessern mit globetrotter m
spezialist für maßgeschneiderte reise
wartet seit über 40 jahren
globetrotter punkt ch